yeah this is a story coming from
Bloomberg nooses tony capaccio which
says indeed that the pentagon the
request that it's making to Congress is
going to be significantly smaller so 51
billion dollars in war funding for the
fiscal year starting october first is
the request that it apparently is going
to put to congress that's according to
officials in congressional aides who
declined to be named that is indeed a
twenty percent reduction from the 64
billion dollars the congress approved
this year it also by the way is the
smallest number since the September 11th
terrorist attacks what this is called is
the overseas contingency operations
funding it will be sent to Congress in
addition to basic defense spending so
this does not defense spending that you
hear about this specifically is allotted
for war funding of that overall defense
spending should amount to about five
hundred and thirty four billion dollars
in a president barack obama's budget so
again here this smaller funding could
reflect the continued withdrawal of US
troops from afghanistan so that accounts
for part of what we're seeing here
perhaps even largely of what we're
seeing here